[Música]
muchas muchas muchas gracias yo siempre
digo dime cómo me recuerdas y te diré en
qué piensas y muchos de ustedes a lo
mejor me recuerdan como sí como sexóloga
verdad
bueno por sixto y sexóloga pero a mí lo
que verdaderamente me mueve es el mundo
de la psicología y me mueve el mundo de
la psicología porque en la sexología si
yo te quito tus ideas erróneas ok y te
enseño un poco de logística es muy fácil
que arregla arreglar tu problema
tu problema pero el mundo la psicología
es distinto y yo hoy vengo a hablar de
lo importante que es la psicología y de
lo importante que es que la psicología
sea tenida mucho más en cuenta
y mucho más
ahora mismo hay muchas ramas de la
psicología y hay mucha gente que está
trabajando en el mundo de la persuasión
psicólogos y psicólogos están utilizando
la psicología como arma de persuasión y
de manipulación
y yo quisiera que la psicología fuera
utilizada
como herramienta de desarrollo humano
creo que es vital que todos estudiamos
psicología y que todos tengamos una
asignatura que sea psicología en la
educación
de lo que les voy a hablar ahora mismo
son conceptos básicos de psicología hay
muchos o que hay muchos que tendríamos
que saber todos y que nos llegan tarde
nos llegan a los 40 a los 50 nos llegan
a través de un coach nos llegan a través
de otras personas pero tendríamos que
tener derecho a conocerlos de primera
mano de la mano de los psicólogos estos
son algunos conceptos importantísimos
que tenemos que conocer importantísimos
que no solo les van a ayudar a ustedes a
entenderse
a comprenderse a sustituir la palabra
culpa por entendimiento sino que van a
entender también que muchas muchos
países muchas de las situaciones
globales también se mueven por las
mismas reglas
la psicología es una asignatura vital y
voy a darles pequeños conceptos para que
se queden con las ganas
vamos a pasar
conceptos que todos tendríamos que
manejar a los 20 años
el concepto de no es significación
autoestima empatía asertividad conducta
evitación millones de conceptos buenos
vamos a empezar por el primero re
significación resignificar algo quiere
decir pero ese mismo acontecimiento
desde otro punto de vista cuando tú ves
las cosas desde otro punto de vista le
das un valor emocional distinto
sí
a veces en la terapia lo que trabajas es
eso como viste tu realidad y la realidad
de la otra persona por ejemplo mi madre
nunca me pelo no me hacía caso
y luego tú le decías bueno háblame de tu
madre pues si mi madre tenía diez
hermanos no llegaba para final de mes
y bonito el rato estaba discutiendo con
mi padre entonces cuánto tiempo dedicaba
a tu padre no te dejaba nada de tiempo
así si me dedicaba tiempo pero no es
suficiente
no es suficiente pero dentro de ese amor
que te quería tu madre que tenía tu
madre te dedicó un porcentaje importante
en comparación con tus hermanos
si te has dado cuenta de eso no nos
empezamos a dar ver las cosas desde otro
punto de vista nos da una visión más
amplia en el que no juzgamos y no
culpamos y yo digo no sería maravilloso
que todos estuviéramos también la
resignificación histórica no puede ser
que yo haya estudiado una historia del
mundo completamente distintos a ustedes
y que mi hijo en eeuu esté estudiando
una historia completamente distinta yo
he aprendido a entender méxico
estudiando otra vez la misma historia
que me enseñaron españa
los he entendido mejor porque he visto
otro punto de vista de significar los
acontecimientos muy importantes nos
vamos al siguiente
pasa por favor queda bien
pasa también vamos a pasarla
autoestima qué es la autoestima lo voy a
explicar de una manera muy muy sencilla
la autoestima es el valor que uno se da
a sí mismo pero no es sólo una
autoestima hay distintas facetas de la
autoestima por ejemplo yo tengo una
autoestima lo mejor de inteligencia muy
buena pero a lo mejor mi autoestima
física es que pues que tengo pocas bubis
y entonces al andar así ustedes en que
se van a fijar en mis hobbies no ok
entonces mi autoestima la personalidad
tiene distintas facetas de la autoestima
y todas es muy difícil tenerlas igual de
fuertes pero si ustedes todas sus
facetas de la autoestima la autoestima
física la intelectual la autoestima
emocional hay mucha gente que siente que
no se merece ser querido
siente que le van a abandonar ok
hay desde niños tendríamos que hacer una
evaluación de cómo es nuestra autoestima
y digo yo y qué tiene que ver esto con
los países pues mucho también porque hay
algunos países que su autoestima
económica y tecnológica es muy alta
verdad y como ahora ese es el valor más
importante pues ellos se creen
superiores a nosotros inferiores pero el
autoestima emocional y la autoestima
musical y la autoestima culinaria
hay algún país con tantos platillos como
méxico no ok entonces nunca se dejen
medir por una autoestima ni ustedes como
individuos
y nosotros como país ok a lo mejor no
somos tan buenos tecnológicamente pero
es curioso que
nosotros y pondría nosotros en méxico
porque ya soy parte de este país y
sabemos como comer sabemos como
disfrutar la vida sabemos como
socializar nos tenemos habilidades
sociales eso también es una autoestima
desarrollada lo estoy haciendo de una
manera muy light para que lo entendamos
ok y los psicólogos no se enfaden
conmigo
y la comunicación también tendríamos que
aprender dos conceptos claves la empatía
y la a ser tibia asertividad es la
capacidad ok de comunicar lo que tú
necesitas de una manera saludable sin
herir a nadie pero dejando claro tus
necesidades
pero qué pasa hay muchas personas que
confunden ser asertivo con agresivo
verdad
ser asertivo se puede aprender lo
podemos aprender en las escuelas ok
hay gente que piensa que es asertiva y
lo que es es narcisista piensa que se
merece todo y te lo dice sin pensar
jamás de tu punto de vista eso no es una
asertividad sana ok hay que aprender a
ser asertivo
porque yo siento
en muchos países no les enseñan a ser
asertivos porque ser asertivos a lo
mejor implica un conflicto
no se pierdan van a ver por dónde voy a
unir los países con las personalidades
la empatía la empatía es la capacidad
que tenemos nosotros de ponernos en el
lugar del otro y saber lo que siente
dicen que las mujeres somos más
simpáticas porque en el fondo estamos
diseñadas para tener
bueno para tener un bebé recién nacido
que ustedes saben que los niños son
prematuros nacen antes de lo que
tendrían que nacer
porque si no nos matarían en el parto
básicamente si crecieran ahí dentro
entonces una mamá al mes ya sabe por los
signos bueno un recién nacido el bebé si
el bebé tiene hambre si tiene dolor es
verdad que las mujeres estamos mucho más
programadas de alguna manera a ser más
empáticas lo que le pasa a la gente
empática que muchas veces se ponen tanto
en el lugar del otro que les pasa que no
se da su lugar que le pasa a la gente
empática que muchas veces por
por evitar el conflicto prefieren callar
no
y yo les digo a mí me decía un amigo es
que en mexico no cumplen las fechas yo
como que no cumplen las fechas dije es
que le pedí a un amigo que es colega que
tuviera esto entregado para mañana digo
pero bueno si esto es imposible y que te
dijeron ellos y en béisbol le dijeron
pues no sé
le tendrían que haberle dicho pues claro
que no te puedo tener eso para mañana es
imposible sí o no pero socialmente
méxico de alguna manera está educado a
ser excesivamente empático evitar el
conflicto y considera que el comunicar
sus necesidades puede ser hasta agresivo
sí o no entonces tendríamos que aprender
a ser más asertivos como país porque nos
sobra empatía nos sobra ponernos en el
lugar del otro pero eso es muy peligroso
porque al final nos olvidamos de
nosotros así que no
y nos vamos a otro concepto que a mí me
parece fascinante que es la habitación
la habitación porque la habitación de
los miedos el miedo el miedo es lo que
nos controla porque en la gran mayoría
de las veces lo queremos evitar por eso
dije en mi presentación que se iba a
llamar fobias porque la fobia desmedida
el miedo desmedida es una fobia entonces
a que tenemos miedo los seres humanos
tenemos miedo al fracaso tenemos miedo a
la crítica tenemos miedo a quedarnos
sólo sí o no y entonces generamos dos
tipos de estrategias hay muchos más pero
me voy a los 20 minutos que tengo dos
tipos de estrategias el programar o sea
el dejar siempre algo que nos cuesta
mucho lidiar con ello hasta el final sí
o no hay algún procrastinador aquí
y la distracción y estamos en una
sociedad que es con el objetivo de
distraernos ok qué cosas son las que nos
están distrayendo constantemente a
nosotros de esa reflexión interna que
tenemos que hacer como persona una el
sexo
el sexo
la búsqueda del placer constante a
través del sexo nos han dicho que hay
que buscar sexo no al sexo y quedando en
su lugar sobre todo los jóvenes a veces
ahora para
les da tanto miedo la intimidad
emocional que utilizan el sexo como un
baile vehículo para ello y se siente más
solos hay que ver qué cosas nos están
distrayendo de nuestra vida de esos
miedos que tenemos de esas cosas con las
que nosotros queremos lidiar ok
me voy al siguiente punto
hay otra cosa que yo considero que es
importante entender que es los traumas
un trauma
un problema o una situación que no ha
sido bien solucionado y que va a marcar
nuestra vida una persona que tiene un
trauma de la vida a través de las de los
lentes de ese trauma por ejemplo si uno
va esta típica mujer que su novio le fue
infiel y como no solucionó bien ese
duelo va a pensar que todos los hombres
son infieles yo no y entonces que le va
a pasar que todas sus relaciones futuras
en vez de vivirlas va a estar buscando
constantemente una infidelidad y qué va
a pasar para acabar con todas sus
relaciones las va sabotear sí o no
entonces hay que ver qué traumas tenemos
hay que ver qué gafas están
cubriendo nuestra realidad aplicando un
filtro negro que no nos deja vivir
nuestra vida plenamente hay un trauma
que yo quiero una resolución de los
traumas que yo creo que es muy
importante que es la validación del
dolor
el que alguien que queremos se dé cuenta
que no se ha hecho daño porque eso te
pide perdón perdón si te ha hecho daño
eso no es perdón
cuando tú buscas que alguien te perdone
ok cuando tú buscas que alguien te
perdone lo que busca es que validez el
dolor que le ha causado pálida melo y yo
les voy a hacer un un pequeño truco de
como validar cómo conseguir digamos
solucionar pequeños traumas ok
familiares por ejemplo típico cuando yo
era niña a los seis años traje una
amiguita y se me cayó el tenedor y mi
padre delante de mi amiguita dijo eres
una inútil y claro yo me fui al colegio
y cada vez que yo hacía algo mis amigos
decían eres una inútil y yo cuando fui
adulta le dije papá es que de ese día
que me llamaste inútil y él me dijo es
hija mía no te olvidas de nada lo hice
mal porque yo no le expliqué a mi papá
el impacto de esa acción de llamarme
inútil en lo que a mí en el daño que me
causó y la inseguridad que me causó en
comer en público cuando yo se lo dije
cuando le dije papá me hiciste daño sin
darte cuenta me cuesta mucho todavía
comer en público sabes lo que te va a
decir tu papá lo siento tanto hijo mío
expliquemos bien por qué nos duelen las
cosas yo sí creo que hay que pedir
perdón perdón personal histórico
pero hay que validar ese dolor ok
porque hay que aceptar que se ha hecho
algo malo y no solo es pedir perdón es
siento tu dolor siento tu dolor que hago
para ayudarte
arreglar este daño
esto lo podemos aplicar en las personas
y en los países y hay muchos países que
tienen la obligación de ayudar a reparar
un daño sobre todo la obligación moral
porque somos humanos y estamos aquí para
buscar lo que tenemos en común que es
construir un mundo mejor y no para
separar nosotros hay maneras de pedir
perdón ok y ya por último
natacha
la humillación
no hay peor cosa que hubiera otro ser
humano cuando tú miras a alguien lo que
le estás diciendo es que aunque tú te
olvides del dolor el resto te lo va a
recordar porque existe en público nunca
humilla si ganas algo a la otra persona
que ha perdido la fe lícitas síganos una
guerra a la persona que ha perdido vas a
ser benévolo dicen que una de las causas
de que hubiera una segunda guerra
mundial es el tratado de versalles la
fuerte humillación que recibieron los
alemanes a la hora de retirse nunca
humilló nunca esto es psicología es
naturaleza humana ok cuando tú causas
tanto daño que has resentimiento y ese
resentimiento es revivir el dolor y
cuando nos duele algo que hacemos a
veces golpeamos más fuerte
estos son reglas de psicología por
último porque no tengo tiempo a nada más
la gratitud se nos olvida que cada vez
que ya agradecemos algo
un pensamiento crea una emoción y esa
emoción te crea una una reacción física
que te hace sentir mejor agradezcamos
todos los días
agradezcamos hay muchas cosas que
podríamos aprender de la psicología
muchísimas creo que no hay desarrollo
humano
sí
es más creo que no hay desarrollo
económico ni tecnológico
nunca lo va a haber si este no va
seguido de desarrollo humano y los
psicólogos la psicología está aquí para
hacer consciencia consciencia y hacer un
punto mejor muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]